you've also mentioned that you
um i think enjoy all kinds of
experiments
including on yourself but i saw a video
where you said you did an experiment
where you tracked all kinds of
information about yourself
and a few others sort of uh
wiring up your home and the this this
little idea that you mentioned
in that video which is kind of
interesting that you thought that
two days worth of data is enough to
capture
majority of the behavior of the human
being
first can you describe what the heck you
did
to collect all the data because it's
fascinating just like little details of
how you collect that data
and also what your intuition behind the
two days is
so first of all it has to be the right
two days but i was i was thinking of a
very specific experiment there's
actually a suite of them that i've been
a part of and other people have done
this of course i've i just sort of
dabbled in that part of the world
but to be very clear the specific thing
that i was talking about
had to do with recording all the ir
going on in my uh
infrared going on in my my house so this
is a long time ago so this is
everything's being curled
by by pressing buttons on remote
controls as opposed to
speaking to alexa or siri or someone
like that and i was just trying to
figure out if you could get enough data
on people to figure out
what they were going to do with their
tvs or their lights my house was
completely wired up at the time
um but you know what i'm about to look
at a movie or i'm about to turn on the
tv or whatever and just see what i could
predict
from it it was kind of surprising it
shouldn't have been
but that's all very easy to do by the
way just capturing all the little stuff
i mean it's a bunch of computer systems
it's really easy to capture if you know
what you're looking for
at georgia tech long before i got there
we had this thing called the aware home
uh where everything was wired up and you
saw you captured everything that was
going on nothing even difficult not with
video
or anything like that just the way that
the system was just capturing everything
um so it turns out that
and i did this with myself and then i
had students and they worked with many
other people
and it turns out at the end of the day
people do the same things
over and over and over again so it has
to be the right two days like a weekend
but it turns out not only can you
predict what someone's going to do next
at the level of what button they're
going to press next on a remote control
um but you can do it with something
really really simple like a
you don't even need a hidden markov
model it's like a mark just simply i
press this
this is my prediction of the next thing
it turns out you can get 93
accuracy just by doing something very
simple and stupid and just counting
counting statistics but what's actually
more interesting is that you could use
that information this comes up again and
again in my work
um if you try to represent people or
objects
by the things they do the things you can
measure about them that have to do with
action in the world
so distribution over actions and you try
to represent them by
the distribution of actions that are
done on them
then you do a pretty good job of sort of
understanding how people are
and they cluster remarkably well um in
fact
irritatingly so uh and so by clustering
people this way
you can maybe you know i got the 93
accuracy of what's the next button
you're going to press but i can get 99
accuracy or somewhere there's about on
the collections of things you might
press and it turns out the things that
you might press
are all related to number to each other
in exactly what you would expect so for
example
all the key all the numbers on the
keypad it turns out all have the same
behavior with respect to you as a human
being
and so you would naturally cluster them
together and just you discover
that numbers are all are related to one
another in some way and all these other
things and then
and here's the part that i think is
important i mean you can see this in all
kinds of things
every individual is different but any
given individual is remarkably
predictable
because you keep doing the same things
over and over again and the two things
that i've learned
in the long time that i've been thinking
about this is people are easily
predictable and people hate when you
tell them that they're easily
predictable
but they are yeah and there you go yeah
what about
let me uh play devil's advocate and
philosophically speaking
is it possible to say that what defines
humans is the outlier
so even though 90 some large percentage
of our behaviors
whatever the signal we measure is the
same and it would cluster nicely
but maybe it's the special moments of
when we
break out of the routine is the
definitive things
and the way we break out of that routine
for each one of us might be different
it's possible i would say that i would
say it a little differently i think
i would make two things one is a i'm
going to disagree with the premise i
think
but that's fine uh i think the way i
would put it is
there are people who are very different
from lots of other people but
they're not zero percent they're closer
to ten percent right so in fact even if
you do this kind of clustering of people
that'll turn out to be the small number
of people they all behave like each
other
even if they individually behave very
differently from from from everyone else
so i think that's kind of important
but what you're really asking i think
and i think it's really a question is
you know what do you do when you're
faced with the situation
you've never seen before what do you do
when you're faced with an extraordinary
situation maybe you've seen others do
and you're actually forced to do
something and
you react to that very differently and
that is the thing that makes you human i
would agree with that
at least at a philosophical level that
it's the
the times when you are faced with
something difficult a decision that you
have to make
uh where the answer isn't easy even if
you know what the right answer is
that's sort of what defines you as the
individual and i think what defines
people
people broadly it's the hard problem
it's not the easy problem it's the thing
that's going to hurt you it's not the
thing
it's not even that it's difficult it's
just that you know that the outcome
is going to be highly suboptimal for you
and i do think that that's a
reasonable place to start for the
question of what makes us human
you